Mary Kay Cabot's got a good job she gets
to write about a lot of fun things
Browns be writer for Cleveland comm
Cleveland Plain Dealer
any negatives to this initially the
reaction Mary Kay no I don't think so I
mean I think Brown fans here are
ecstatic over the boon about this and I
don't think anyone is crying over what
the Browns gave up I mean they gave up a
number 17 overall pick that you know
maybe they could have used it on a DK
Metcalf or a good defender but why not
go out and use that on a superstar
receiver that could really help take
Baker Mayfield to the next level and
maybe maybe even catapult this team into
a Super Bowl before too long yeah I
looked at the odds the updated odds and
Cleveland really jumped up there I think
14 to 1 to win the Super Bowl which okay
that might be a little bit of a stretch
here but I'm looking at the skilled
position players for this team Mary Kay
and they rival just about anybody in the
NFL right now if I look at running back
both wide receivers the quarterback
tight end situation that's a lot of
pressure on Freddie kitchens coming in
there's a first-year head coach to make
all this work you know what I don't
think Freddie's looking at it like that
I think he seemed very aggressive and I
think he's looking at it as though now
he has even more weapons to power that
high-flying offense of his and if you
look at what John Dorsey is doing he's
really basically kind of duplicating
what he built in Kansas City before he
left there he's got his own Patrick
mahomes in Baker Mayfield he's got his
own obj in you know his own Tyree killed
it obj he signed Kareem hunch who's
going to be a big big part of this
offense once he comes off of his
suspension so now you've got an offense
that should be able to rival the Kansas
City's the New England's the Rams and
the like I'm also looking at where they
are in the division you know
Pittsburgh's lost lay beyond on Antonio
Brown we're not quite sure what to
expect out of them Ravens lost their
defense but they somehow find these
pieces to fit him in there and then you
got the Bengals so the class of the AFC
North
- well right now I I would have to say
it's the Browns I think that this trade
pushed them over the top into the strong
contender for the AFC North north I
think you're looking at a week in which
Antonio Brown left the Steelers at the
same time the Browns added that
blockbuster star receiver to their
lineup so now the Browns have their two
killer bees and Beckham and Baker and
the Steelers lost two of theirs in Bell
and and Brown so I would have to say
that the Browns would be favored to win
the AFC North but you know whenever you
have Ben Roethlisberger on your team I
don't think you can count out the
Steelers that is a smart organization
they know how to draft they know how to
add players and and he always can work
up a little bit of a fury for the Browns
passing on him in the draft I'm always
curious when a star player gets traded
that you know there's that jubilation we
got somebody but there's a reason why
the Giants traded him why do you think
the Giants got rid of obj well I think
you can look to you know some of the
interviews that he did last year where
he criticized Eli he criticized the
organization he criticized the coaching
staff and he complained about you know
not being able to get the bottle in the
way that he wanted to and contribute in
the ways that he wanted to I don't think
pet Shermer came in there and
appreciated the way that that odell
behaved and you know Patrignano was here
in Cleveland for a while and I know for
a fact that he just doesn't tolerate the
kind of stuff that that Odell did there
he you know he got got into it here pet
rumor did with Joe Hayden a few times
and you know he just doesn't mess around
with that sort of thing so I think those
guys clashed I don't think that helped
at all I think it chain your scenery is
exactly what is needed for Odell and I
think what he really wants as a
quarterback that can get him the ball
early and often and I think Baker will
do that I'd love to see the Browns on
hard knocks wouldn't this be an
unbelievable year for them to be on hard
knocks but I will tell you they will be
all over every kind of media that you
can think it is going to be
a circus here the likes of which you
know we really haven't seen I mean it
was nuts when Johnny Manziel was here
but this is going to be our top that but
how does this compare to the frenzy that
when LeBron LeBron came back to where
the Browns aren't now it's a football
town and and I know LeBron coming back
and the possibility winning a
championship but can you differentiate
between the two
well you know I've been saying you know
they lost their LBJ and got their odj
but and fans are so excited about that
but I do think that this still is a
Browns town and I think that there will
be even more people at the parade in
downtown Cleveland if the Cleveland
Browns can go out there and and finally
win a Super Bowl and do with these
long-suffering Browns fans have been
waiting for so many years
I mean LeBron is larger than life but I
do think that the the Baker Beckham
combo is going to rival that man you got
a good gig Mary Kay you've got a good
job yeah well I thank you Mary Kay I
know you're busy but we appreciate your
time as always
Thank You Aunt Mary Kay Kevin for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]